boo like have podcast special guests in
here my guy Q my guy Ramses AKA Civic
Cipher what up though for people who
don't know what Civic Cipher is
Ramses I'll let you educate the people
Civic Cipher is you should uh put the
mic in front of YouTube Ramses it is a
radio show
that uh exists to
um give
the hip-hop Community a little bit more
insight into the goings-on politically
in this country and to give a voice to
the activist element
um uh that moves to create a better
day-to-day life for black and brown
marginalized impoverished communities
Etc what was the inspiration for
starting the show
uh really it was 2020 you know folks
getting out on the street
um and protesting you know let us know
that there was a gap in there was a
gaping hole in the previous space
yes I remember that
anyway tell me more about the gaping
hole no no I'm not going to tell you
about that you should talk about that
anyway there was a gaping hole in the
media space sure sure and uh in the
media space
um you know uh we are both DJs and
broadcasters um I'm talking to you like
you don't notice but you got to tell
everybody else for people who don't know
Rams this is like my best friend in the
entire world best man in my wedding yes
you know I've known Kevin since he was
three years old yes so the reason
bootleg Kev is all into hip-hop this is
true it's all him it's all his fault
it's literally his fault it's his fault
you have to play guys when we were
little you know little toys now I play
with guys but that was what you call it
you call it guys guys yeah like action
figures action figures yes so so
lifelong friend uh best friend but but
yeah um in that in the media space there
wasn't anyone talking about what was
going on the streets no one giving a
voice to the movement no one talking
about you know what explaining the
concepts defund the police how do we you
know create programs to kind of mitigate
you know economic you know instability
and and
you know bring just an activist element
to the to the airwaves we was just if
you would have turned on the radio at
the time it was just rapping and dancing
and singing and fashion and or it was
just very like uh you know obviously in
radio there's not a lot of
uh time or space to really
dive into those conversations right
outside of surface level things right
and so that's exactly what we pushed
back against because
um you know it's it's one thing says it
a lot better but I'll try to get you
started there's one thing to
you know profit from Black Culture
because you know a lot of folks at the
top they didn't really look like the
community that who's coaching mostly
nobody at the top there you go mostly
mostly exactly so a lot of them people
were benefiting from it but they didn't
really have a vested interest in
whatever outcomes took place on the
street and we fought against that uh
that
imbalance and so you know yes we we take
a moment we turn the songs off we turn
the music off we have conversations we
educate not just black and brown people
but everybody who's communities yeah
right anybody listens to hip-hop we
figured they can be an ally to black and
brown communities they need to
understand the conversations the
struggles the challenges and then by
having those conversations long form in
spaces where people are because it's
hard for folks to seek Out programs like
ours if you're we don't seek out
you know Vietnamese programming no
disrespect but I don't feel like it's
creative for me so I don't expect you
know non-black people to seek out what
would be considered black programming if
they don't feel like it's for them right
so by putting it in the media space
where hip-hop music is can consumed
Black Culture is consumed it feels and
our opinion feels a little bit more
accessible for our listeners and so this
is how we've been able to
um connect with you know radio stations
around the country listeners around the
country it's also available in podcast
form right sure absolutely absolutely so
you know we've been doing that we've
been doing uh and then since then of
course the black Information Network uh
which is a subsidiary of I heart media
has reached out and they've kind of
tapped on us to kind of expand the show
um and then I I do a podcast for them as
well so it's been it's been a wild ride
but you know we're making some progress